[Music]
all right speaking of covid a new
vaccine against it could soon be
available to you
but what if you don't want to get it
could your workplace
force you to receive it eric palacios
has the answers
erica i really think this next chapter
of
covid is going to be fascinating and
possibly
as contentious as it has been up to this
point because now we're talking about
vaccines
and and what is required when it comes
to
people working for someone else can an
employer
require an employee to get a vaccine
that's a great question and the answer
is it depends
uh for most private employers you can
ask your employees to provide a
proof of a vaccine if they work in the
health industry
or an industry that deals a lot with
customers or clients like a restaurant
industry
so they can ask employees to have
a vaccine okay then what happens if an
employee refuses to do so
also uh something that is bound to come
up there are a few reasons
why you can legally resist
of getting a vaccine one of those is if
you
have a condition or an illness which
a vaccine will make worse or
put you in danger of getting sick under
the american with disabilities act
you can exempt out of this
also uh for some getting a vaccine with
certain
uh elements in the vaccine blood
derivatives or or different substances
might violate
their religious beliefs so if the
vaccine
violates your religious beliefs then you
can also
uh reject it but it could get
complicated so very fast
then does an employer have the right to
fire an employee who refuses to get the
vaccine
well what you would hope is that they
find another
reasonable alternative maybe uh switch
the employee's
position to something that he doesn't
have direct contact
uh with the customers or somehow uh
accommodate
the employee's request to not be
vaccinated
but again depending on the industry uh
it can be
a reason for for termination do you
anticipate there will be a lot of
legal matters surrounding the vaccines
i do because the law is not real clear
on this
when it's not a final uh approved
medical treatment uh normally that takes
about you know three to five years for
any type of new medicine or vaccine to
be fully approved
what we have now is just uh vaccines
rolling out under an emergency
uh provision uh because then they need
to
to be out before there's been long term
uh
investigation and studies on the all of
the effects
because of this uh it the vaccine
doesn't have the same
protections and rights as a medicine
or a vaccine that's been fully vetted
and fully approved
so for this reason the law is not too
clear and i'm sure we're going to see
a lot of contention and a lot of
lawsuits going back and forth
by employees that have been terminated
for not receiving the vaccine
or maybe even employees that have been
forced to take the vaccine and have some
about
somehow been affected yeah it is the
next chapter eric thank you
so much for your time appreciate it
always
thanks for having me great conversation
there for more information give eric
palacios and associates a call at
702-444-7777